the governor of Tennessee has signed
into law a bill which Shields gun
manufacturers from lawsuits this is a
disaster now you might say David sir
wait a second you believe gun
manufacturers should be able to be held
liable for the things that people do
with their guns but social media
companies should not be held liable for
the content that a user might upload
aren't you a hypocrite David and the
answer is of course not gun
manufacturers and social media companies
do very different things gun
manufacturers make weapons that can be
deadly and are not the same as a
platform that allows users to express
themselves these are completely
different things yes guns can be used
for different purposes and yes social
media can be used for different purposes
but we're talking about dramatically
different things here